if the left is able to create Sanctuary
States for rapists and murderers Thugs
and criminals
I don't think it's too big of an ass for
Ron DeSantis critic to create a
sanctuary state for a former president
who's being persecuted
by a soros-funded D.A yeah so it's an
interesting legal question can a
governor block the extradition of an
indicted person from their state to the
state in which they are indicted can a
governor do that Governors do have the
power to block extradition of a person
who is wanted in another state but in
very limited circumstances a governor
May block the extradition of a person if
the governor determines that the
person's rights would be violated in the
extradition or if the governor believes
that the request for extradition is
politically motivated or improper